Hello friends, welcome to the program
I'd like to know. This is a question and
answer program where you have the
opportunity to also participate by
sending your questions. We have amazing
questions for today and I am here in the
company of pastor Steven Boore. Uh thank
you for inviting me uh and and being
with you in the panel here.
To the contrary, thank you so much for
being willing to help us here with all
of the duties and responsibilities that
you have in your district.
>> Thank you, Pastor Boore. and I am Daniel
Miranda, a pastor of the Gorosian and
Sanger Bilingual Seventh Day Adventist
Churches. Uh before we pray, we want to
remind you that if you want to send your
questions, you can do so at the
following email address, tvstv.org.
Once again, tvsv.org.
Uh send the questions there. There is a
group of people that will go over your
questions and select them to this
program. Before we begin, I'm going to
open the program with a word of prayer.
Heavenly Father, we are in heaven. We
thank you so much for this other program
I'd like to know. We recognize that we
don't have the necessary wisdom to
answer these questions. We pray Lord
that you may give us the words and the
scriptures that we need to answer these
questions correctly. We pray all this in
Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Okay.
The first question for today comes from
the country of Guyana.
>> This is William. He says, "Greetings to
you all. I really appreciate your answer
to my question last time. We know
historically that the 10 tribes were
taken captive in Assyria and
intermarried there. But in the New
Testament, we read about Elizabeth's
from the lineage of Levi. This is the
Elizabeth uh John the Baptist mother.
and Anna from the tribe of Asia.
How were they identified with those
tribes lost
their pure lineage when those tribes
lost their pure lineage?
>> Well, I think the bottom line is that
not everybody lost their lineage.
>> Yes.
>> Uh there were individual who still who
individuals who still remain faithful to
the Lord.
>> Correct. and uh did not become
intermingled with the Assyrians and with
other nations that were represented
there. Uh so uh in this case you know
that Anna was a was a wonderful woman.
>> Uh and uh and we know that Elizabeth was
also a wonderful woman.
>> Uh obviously they kept record of the
lineage.
>> Yes.
>> Uh by the way the the Assyrian captivity
of the tribes of the north was in 723
BC. Mhm.
>> Uh and um you know the Samaritans
actually came as a result of uh that
that fall of the 10 tribes of the north.
>> So it doesn't mean that everybody uh
lost their identity. In other words,
>> that's correct. And one evidence for
that is when we look at the history
during the times of King Josiah and the
reformation that he accomplished.
>> Uh the Bible tells us that he even went
to some of the tribes of the north of
the north and some of these people
returned to the Lord uh and worshiped
the true God. So it tells us that there
was still a remnant in those tribes that
um that they returned to the Lord during
the time of Josiah's reformation.
>> So yes uh a good part of these tribes uh
mixed and intermarried with the
Assyrians and the pagan nations. But the
fact that we have um you know in this
case Anna from the tribe of Asia and
others uh is a is an insinuation or is
um an example that some still remain
faithful. And Levi is easier to explain
because the tribe of Levi was connected
to the century and the century was in
Judah. And and we know that even after
the Babylonian captivity, many Levites
return to Jerusalem. So the tribe of
Levi is is easier to explain. But but I
also
tri the tribes in in Israel does not
necessarily imply that they were pure
blood because we see a lot of
intermarriage throughout history. Even
in the Old Testament, still they were
part of of of Israel. you know Paul uh
he is uh from from the tri he was from
the tribe of Benjamin uh the Bible says
>> but he was living in uh gentile
territory. So we see we see uh these
dynamics in the Bible that when a tribe
or someone from a certain tribe is
mentioned it does not imply necessarily
that they were of pure descent or pure
blood at least in the New Testament
times.
>> Mhm. Okay.
>> Yes.
>> Very good. Okay, we go to the next
question. This one comes from the
country of Zambia. Chumba
and um this is brother Chumba from
Zambia. He says, "I have follow I like
to know for some time now and I always
look forward to watching a new episode."
That's good. I was reading First Kings
chapter 3 concerning how the kings of
Israel, Judah, and Edom attacked Moab.
This sparked two questions in my mind.
Number one, violence in the Old
Testament. I find it difficult to
understand how attacking another nation
seems to be sanctioned by God since
Elisha in verse 18 says that the Lord
the Lord will deliver the Moabites into
their hand. The Moabites may have been
evil people, but I am very uncomfortable
with the killing of people of a nation
by another nation. [snorts] and God
sanctions it especially since this is
not an isolated incident. Please help me
understand.
Let's deal with this first question
because he has another question related
to that. But let's deal with this first
one uh about the killing of people and
this holy war that we find in in the Old
Testament. Perhaps if you have something
to say about that, Pastor Boore. Well,
the bottom line is that God ordered
uh the destruction of the city of the
inhabitants of Canaan.
>> So ultimately uh the responsible
uh party would be the Lord.
>> Yes.
>> For the destruction of these nations. Um
of course we need to understand the
situation of these nations.
>> Mhm. uh and uh you know God is is uh
absolutely just in everything that he
does and absolutely merciful in what he
does.
>> Yes.
>> Uh and so
our wisdom and our knowledge is so
limited compared to God's knowledge and
wisdom,
>> right?
>> U there are many things that we're never
going to understand in this life. But
[snorts] when we get to the other side
and we ask the Lord, the Lord is going
to say, "This is the reason I did this."
And it's going to make perfect sense
because God is absolutely merciful and
God is absolutely just. Uh so um you
know the violence in the Old Testament
does not particularly
um bother me when God told Israel to
destroy those nations uh of Canaan or in
this case the Moabites
who were relatives of Jacob of Israel of
Abraham but uh but you know they became
enemies of God's people.
>> Yes. Absolutely. There are certain
principles that we need to understand in
order to make sense of of this and and
see the justice of God. Let me mention a
few of them. In re in Genesis 15, we
find the covenant that God makes with
Abraham.
>> And in that covenant, God promises
Abraham that this is the land that he's
going to give to his descendants, the
Jebusites and the and the Perizzites and
the Canaanite and all of these nations.
But then he says that
not now until the iniquity of the
Amorite is full.
>> So God did not give Abraham and he was
dwelling in the land already but he
didn't give him the land because there
was still hope for these people. They
have not reached the the fullness of
their iniquity. We could say probation
had not closed to them if you will. But
by the by the time of Moses, several
generations later, they have just passed
the line beyond reach. God could not do
anything for them. And and it is until
then in God's justice that again God can
inflict this kind of judgments and
punishments on on certain nations. This
is the same thing that God is going to
do at the end with the destruction of
the wicked. If we reason from this
perspective, then God would not be just
if he destroys the wicked in the ends of
times. So there there are different
factors that lead God to allow the
attack of Israel to to to certain
nations. Most of the times it is when
his honor and and the name and his name
is in is at stake when they have openly
and defiantly
um attack or defy the name of the Lord
which was pending on Israel and the
worship in the century and the promised
land. Many of these nations mocked God.
And we have to understand that that in
those times whoever God won because the
each nation had their own god uh and
they would go to war with those gods. Um
if if Israel would have allowed these
nations to continue harass them, the
name of God was at at stake because the
other nations would see like oh the God
of Israel is not powerful enough and and
they would humiliate and put to shame
the God of Israel. So so we see we got
to see this from the perspective of
God's honor and the vindication of his
character that that sometimes this
happens. Now, it was never God's purpose
for Israel to conquer
uh by war or military conquest. We see
that in the book of Exodus chapter 23,
God wanted to do it in a natural way,
little by little with the with the wasp
and and the and the wild animals of the
land.
But because of their lack of faith, then
they had to use the weapon. And here God
is working at the level in which the
Israelites were. They were not
completely faithful to God. They were
not where God wanted them to be. Yet in
their weakness or in their spiritual
condition, God still is using them to
show his name and who he is before the
nations.
>> You know, it's amazing. And uh some
people say, you know, why does God allow
evil to continue
uh always worse and worse and worse? Why
does God allow why doesn't God just
finish it? But the same people say, "How
could a God of love finish them off?" So
So really, they're kind of talking out
of both sides of their mouth,
>> right? uh you know it doesn't make any
difference as far as I'm concerned
whether God tells Israel to destroy
these nations
or whether God does it himself.
>> Yeah.
>> Do people complain that God uh that God
destroyed the world by a flood
>> directly? He did it that he destroyed
Sodom and Gomorrah that he did it
>> that at the second coming he's going to
destroy the wicked.
>> Yeah. Ultimately,
when God destroys a city or a nation,
it's because they're beyond the point of
no return. That's right.
>> Like you were saying, uh, and only God
knows when a person or a nation has
reached that point.
>> Exactly.
>> In other words, the Amorites committed
the unpardonable sin
>> as as a nation.
>> Because nations can commit the
unpardonable sin, too.
>> Yes. Take for example the United States.
Uh Ellen White says that when the United
States enacts a Sunday law
and uh and eventually gives a death
decree against those who do not observe
the first day of the week. She says that
national apostasy will be written in the
books of heaven
>> beyond the point of no return.
>> And she says that national apostasy will
lead to national ruin.
>> Yes. uh you know you take for example uh
the fall of Babylon in the days of of uh
Nebuchadnezzar.
>> You have been weighed in the balances.
>> Yes,
>> that's a that's a word for judgment and
you have been f you have uh been found
wanting and so uh Babylon was beyond the
point of no return. Uh and therefore
Babylon fell. So, you know, let's not
question
with our limited understanding, our
limited wisdom
>> the acts of God. Let's know for sure
that God is just in everything that he
does.
He's loving and merciful in everything
that he does. In fact, the wicked
actually ask God to destroy them
>> because they cannot stand the idea of
living in the presence of God that they
have learned to despise.
>> Yes.
>> So, so you know, God is simply giving
them the result of their own choice.
>> That's correct.
>> God is not arbitrarily destroying them.
He's g he's given them a choice and
they've exercised their choice. And you
know back to this question, God was
merciful with the Moabites
when when Moses they had to go through
these different route up to the Jordan
River. He said don't fight against your
brethren Edom and Moab and Hmon.
>> But um but later these nations become
even more and more wicked. By the time
of the of the conquest of Canaan,
>> these nations had not reached that point
yet,
>> right? But we see as as as they continue
they become more and more wicked and and
that's why we see these wars against
against the two nations.
>> Now by by the way I just want to mention
that uh
>> u in a newsletter that is going to come
out in the summer of this year. Uh I
have an article that I'm writing
presently on the issue of holy wars.
And uh I'm going to deal with all of
these uh all of these issues of why uh
God told Israel to destroy the the lands
of Canaan etc. We're going to go through
it in detail so we can understand a
little bit better uh that God is not
being arbitrary that God is just and God
is loving in everything that he does.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you. So the second
question coming again from our brother
Champa. Uh, it says, "It seems to me
that there were more wars in the Old
Testament times than now." Or maybe I
could be wrong because I am speaking
from the perspective of being born and
bred in a country that has never
experienced wars since independence.
Zambia is really peaceful. Glory to God.
That's good to hear.
>> Amen. This then makes me wonder what
Jesus meant when he said in Matthew 24
that we shall hear of wars and rumors of
wars as signs of the end. Since we seem
to have fewer words now than in the Old
Testament times, I look forward to
hearing your response. May God bless you
and reward you greatly for the work that
you're doing.
Now, it it's true that I've heard that
argument before about the signs of the
times in Matthew 24 when we say, "Oh,
wars and rumors of war." And people say,
"Hey, but there has always been wars,
>> right? There's always been pestilence,
earthquakes."
>> Exactly. Now, this here is in a specific
context
of of of wars on a worldwide scale, more
bloody, more repetitive. For example, we
take first and second world wars. I
mean, there have always been wars, but
nothing like that. It was just horrific.
a lot of bloodshed uh new weapons and
and and also we understand in Matthew in
Matthew chapter 24 it begins with this
first sign which is the deceptions uh
there will be false Christ uh be not
deceived this false Christ will appear
uh you know angels pretending to be
Christ and things like that so so when
these manifestations spiritual
manifestations begin to happen
then we're going to see all these signs
repeated again in in a greater scale. So
when we see all those elements combined
then we know that for sure the time the
time is near and we're already seeing
that and and we know the spirit of
prophecy tells us that as we get near
the close of time these events will will
happen in more intensity and frequency.
>> Yeah. In fact in great controversy after
describing
uh what we call natural disasters
they're really supernatural because the
devil God is allowing the devil to cause
them. Yes.
>> Uh she says that these disasters will
become more and more frequent.
>> Yes.
>> And more and more disastrous.
>> Um I think that's great controversy 589
and 590 where she makes these comments.
Um but we can't stay only in Matthew
chapter 24 for the signs
>> because there's all kinds of signs in
the book of Revelation.
>> Absolutely.
>> The ascent of the United States in
global power. uh the the the the healing
of the wound of the papacy.
>> Uh you know there are many other signs
that are described in other parts of
scripture.
>> Yes.
>> And so you have to look at at the
accumulation and the growth of all of
the signs. You know it's kind of like uh
perfect storm.
>> What is a perfect storm? A perfect storm
is when all the meteorological
uh details converge
>> negative at the same time. Yeah.
>> Then you have the perfect storm,
>> right?
>> You know, we have, for example, we have
an American pope.
>> We have a president who who's in favor
of Christian nationalism.
>> Uh we have we have social unrest that
you has never seen before. Riots
everywhere.
>> Uh we're seeing all kinds of of signs
>> all happening at the same time.
>> That's right. Yeah, there's been an
earthquake in Lisbon and a earthquake
over there and a pandemic of 1918, but
we're seeing more and more how all of
these signs are being fulfilled at the
same time, right?
>> And to a greater degree.
>> And I like that perspective because we
have to see this collectively. You know,
as you said, all the factors working
together. Yes, there has been some of
these things before, but but the
conditions were not so in the world to
usher in the last events of Earth's
history. But what Jesus is predicting is
a convergence of different factors that
will come together and and create this
perfect storm in in the final events.
>> And of course, uh you know, uh the wars
that existed in the Old Testament, we
might call regional wars.
>> They were regional. Yes.
>> Yeah. They were reg regional, you know,
uh mainly in Asia
>> and in Europe later on. Uh but but today
it's global.
>> It is,
>> you know, China, Russia, the United
States all vying for world power. I
mean, and and the nations allying
themselves with one side or the other,
you know, on a global scale.
>> Yeah.
>> It's very different than the regional
wars that existed uh in Old Testament
periods.
>> That's correct.
Okay, very good. Thank you. Let's go to
the next question. Uh, this one is from
David McDuffy from Auxnar, California.
Can you please explain the third angel's
message and how it is the 1880 message
in Verity? If the 1888 message had been
accepted at Minneapolis, would it have
brought in brought in the latter rain
and finish their work? I know that you
might have a quote uh regarding that. I
can I can briefly explain why I believe
call Ellen White called this message the
the third angel's message in verity the
1888 message you know you have to study
history and what was what was going on
during that conference and what were the
accusations there was a major debate on
the law in Galatians and um the
accusation of the older uh pioneers
was that was that Jones and Wagner were
doing away with the law and the
observance of the law. They were going
the evangelical way. That was one of the
accusations.
>> [snorts]
>> But Ellen Y defends or or or actually
she responds to that and she says no
actually they are giving the law the
right place because unfortunately
Adventism had reached a point where it
had become very legalistic where uh
basically salvation was by works by
keeping the law and then and this is the
verse that was very fundamental in that
discussion revelation 14:12 the the
conclusion of third angel's message
message here is the patience of the
saints here are those that keep the
commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus. Ellen White says that the church
had dwelt so much on the commandments of
God but they had not touched on the
faith of Jesus. It is through the faith
of Jesus that we can keep the
commandments of God. And that is the
conclusion of the three angels messages.
In other words, those that that will not
worship the beast and its image are
those that keep the commandments of God
and have the faith of Jesus. And of
course, the first angel's message
alludes to that. It talks about the
Sabbath day uh and it talks about
fearing God. That has to do with keeping
the commandments.
>> You know, it's interesting uh that our
at our summit last year
>> uh we dealt with the armor of God.
>> And I prepared some study notes uh that
are available from Secrets Unsealed uh
of the presentations that I made there.
And uh I just like to read a couple of
statements from the spirit of prophecy.
>> Yes. uh that refer to what happened in
1888.
>> Um Ellen White did not discard the law,
>> right?
>> Uh you know, there's been entire books
that have been written on 1888,
but Ellen White encapsulated the message
just in this short quotation.
It's found in testimonies to ministers,
page 91 and 92. And then I'm going to
read another one. Um
it the 1888 message presented
justification through faith in the
shity.
Christ is the shity the guarantee. It
invited the people to receive the
righteousness of Christ.
>> Yes.
>> Justification
which is made manifest in obedience to
all the commandments of God.
>> That's it.
>> There there's a whole thing
>> that encapsulates the entire message.
And then in another place review and
Herald June 4 1895 she wrote
righteousness within is testified by
righteousness without.
>> Yes.
>> The righteousness by which we are
justified is imputed. The righteousness
by which we are sanctified is imparted.
The first that is the imputed
righteousness is our title to heaven.
The second is our fitness for heaven. We
will not go to heaven without the title
or the fitness.
>> Exactly. And yes, it's true. If if this
message had been accepted, would have
brought in the latter rain and finished
the work.
>> Thank you for joining us in our program.
See you next time. God bless you.